[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر براكي
احييكم وهذه العربيه
360 حيث الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
بعد لاعبه السهام والمتسلقات صار خادم
تتحدى رقعه القمع الايراني للاحتجاجات
بالشطرنج
بورنو
اوكرانيا مدمره وفاتوره الحرب تجاوزت
تريليون دولار
والعربيه
وفي عناويننا الاخرى ايضا
[موسيقى]
تنبؤات الروسيه على شكل امنيات فيها ماسك
رئيسا لامريكا كيف الاجابه العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
صار خادم لاعبه شطرنج ايرانيه احتجت على
طريقتها ضد قمع النظام الايراني للنساء
ودعما للتظاهرات ضد او بعد مقتل
لاعبه شطرنج شاركت في دوره دوليه من دون
ارتداء الحجاب لتكون الاحدث من بين
رياضيات ايرانيات
ظهرنا في منافسه دون ارتداء الحجاب منذ
بدا الاحتجاجات اما الشاب الايراني محمد
مرادي الذي يبلغ من العمر 38 عاما والمقيم
في اليوم جنوب وسط فرنسا فلم يجد وسيله
غير القاء نفسه
احتجاجا على قمع السلطات الايرانيه مراد
وفي مقطع فيديو مثيره على انستغرام قال
انه قرر الانتحار في نهر الفرنسي واراد ان
يفعل ذلك ليظهر للجميع ان الايرانيين
بحاجه الى مساعده
[موسيقى]
تداول انشطون فيديو صرخات او يظهر صرخات
ابنه احد ضحايا الاحتجاجات وهو كمال احمد
بور الابنه تبكي على الوالد في مراسم مرور
40 يوما على مقتله كان كمال احمد بور اصيب
بجروح خطيره على ايدي قوه الامن الايرانيه
وتوفي في طريقه الى المستشفى في الثامن
عشر من نوفمبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
رغم انه هو
لا يقل عن 476 الا ان الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس تعاهد بعدم الرحم اتجاه
المتظاهرين رئيس وصف المحتجين بالاعداء
وهددهم بمعامله قصيره
لطالما تصدرت ايران قائمه دول العالم من
حيث حالات الاعدام لكن العام 2022 جاء
استثنائيا
فتنفيذ احكام الاعدام ارتفع بحسب منظم
هارانا بنسبه 88% هذا العام مقارنه بالعام
الماضي عدد من صدرت او نفذ ضدهم احكام
بالاعدام في ايران خلال هذا العام بلغ 500
شخصا من بينهم 11 امراه وخمسه مدانين تقل
اعمارهم عن 18 عاما اي يعتبرون اطفال بحسب
القانون الدولي
الاسباب متعددت فمن ادانات بجرائم
المخدرات الى اتهامات بالتعاون مع اسرائيل
ومؤخرا بدا القضاء الايراني في اصدار
احكام بالاعدام في حق المشاركين في
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه بهدف ترهيب المحتجين
بعد ان فشلت اجراءات النظام الاخرى مثل
حال شرطه الاخلاق في انهاء التظاهرات
مؤسستهرانه التي اصدرت التقرير عن
الاعدامات تتهم النظام باستخدام الاعدام
التعسفي سلاحا في وجه معارضيه ولا فتاه
الى ترتيب المحافظات والمدن الايرانيه من
حيث نسب الاعدام هذه النسب بحسب المنظمات
تظهر سعي طهران الاستهداف حقوق الاقليات
الدينيه والمذهبيه والقوميه تقريره رانا
كشف ان ثمانيه عشر ونصف في المئه من
الاعدامات في عام 2022 تمت في محافظه
بلوشستان ذات الاغلبيه السنيه ثم تلتها
محافظه البرج في المرتبه الثانيه باكثر من
16% كما ان اكثر حالات الاعدام كانت في
سجن زهدان ورجائي شهر الاعدامات التعسفيه
في ايران اثاره انتقادات قويه من منظمات
حقوقيه دوليه شككت في مصداقيه احكام
الاعدام التي يصدرها القضاء الايراني
وخاصه ضد المحتجين الذين فشلت محاولات
النظام في اخماد تظاهراتهم حتى الان
نتابع هذه الصور التي تصلنا من لوس انجلوس
لحاله المطارات هناك بعد يعني العاصفه
الثلجيه التي وصفت بعصفه القرن التي تضرب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عموما في جانب
من الصوره نشاهد لوس انجلوس في الجانب
الاخر نشاهد الصور من بافلو الاكثر تضررا
التي توصف بالمدفونه تحت الثلوج والمحاصره
بها من كل حد وصوب كان هناك توقعات بان
تتحسن احوال الطقس في خاصه في شرق
الولايات المتحده وولايات وسط الغرب اليوم
بعد ايام على هذه العاصفه الثلجيه التي
وصفت ايضا بعاصفه القرن كانت تاريخيه
بالفعل وقد خفض طبعا درجات الحراره الى ما
دون الصفر مع اجبر بسبب الثلوج والرياح
القويه سلطات الطيران على الغاء اكثر من
15,000 رحله جويه امريكيه في الايام
الاخيره
في ذلك نحو اربعه الاف رحله فقط الاثنين
وفقا لفلايت اواير موقع تتبع حركه الطيران
اذا نشاهد جزء همم اليمين من الصوره او من
الشاشه همم
في همم من بافلو التي تعتبر محور الازمه
حاليا كيف ايضا حاكمه نيويورك كانت قالت
انها بالتاكيد عاصفه القرن همم كانت
الكثير من اا يعني كان هناك عشرات من
الوفيات بسبب هذه العاصفه الثلجيه اضافه
الى اضرار همم يعني لا تحصر حتى الان طبعا
كان دعا الى اعلان حال الطوارئ همم في همم
نيويورك اضافه الى ان الارصاد الجويه
توقعت استمرار تساقط الثلوج في بافلوه وان
تضاف طبقه جديده الى الثلوج المتراكمه هذه
الثلوج التي ادت الى شل المدينه وانهيار
خدمات الطوارئ لم تعد تستطيع التحمل همم
ولكن همم اخر معلومات الارصاد الجويه
الثلاثاء صباحا توقعت ان تميل درجه
الحراره الى الاعتدال في الشرق والغرب
الاوسط ولكنها في الايام المقبله ولكنها
حذرت في الوقت نفسه من ان السفر في هذه
المناطق يبقى محفوظه
بالمخاطر كان عدد الوفيات ارتفع اذا في
اليومين الماضيين
وكان هناك عدد ايضا من الذين حصروا في
سياراتهم بسبب الثلوج وفي منازلهم التي
انقطع عنها التيار الكهربائي الوضع همم
يعني يعتبر سويا ومؤلما بالنسبه الى
كثيرين خاصه من اولئك الذين تجمد في البرد
همم طبعا هناك همم
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه في يعني مشكله معها بسبب الوضع
ولكن يعني لا يبدو ذلك واضحه اذا هذا ما
يصلنا من مطار لوس انجلوس ومن احب
مطاراتها
للوضع هناك بعد تعليق الاف رحلات رحلات
الطيران اضافه الى الجانب الاخر من الشاشه
المحاصره كليا بالثلوج
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ملفنا الاول
بشقه وشق الاول منه تحديدا الان تظاهرات
قبل ان ننتقل الى الشق الثاني المتعلق
بالنووي من عمان ينضم الينا رئيس وحده
دراسات الايرانيه في معهد الشرق الاوسط
للاعلام ودراسات سياسيه دكتور نبيل العتوم
اهلا وسهلا فيك دكتور نبيل مره جديده على
شاشه العربيه نبدا بالشق الاول وهو
المتعلق بالتظاهرات تقييمك وانت يعني
متابع عن كتب وخبير اا لمده طويله جدا في
شان الايراني
تقديرك لما وصلت اليه الامور حتى الان ما
الذي استطعت ان تحققه هذه التظاهرات حتى
الان ما الذي كسبته ما الذي حجم ما خسره
النظام حتى الان
مساء الخير استاذ طاهر يعني هذه
الاحتجاجات مميزاتها انها مازالت مستمره
لغايه هذه اللحظه
بدات تنتشر بشكل اكبر وبشكل اوسع احنا
اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من 100 و87 بؤره
ساخنه موجوده على امتداد الجغرافيا
الايرانيه هذا بعكس وجود اراده شعبيه غير
مسبقه لاستمرار هذه التظاهرات بدات بشكل
عفوي دون ان يكون لديها قياده او كاريزما
تقود هذه التظاهرات ثم تم اخذ عن ذلك وجود
تنسيقيات بدات تدير هذه الاحتجاجات
وتنظمها عن طريق وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وعن طريق التواصل مع المحتجين والمتظاهرين
على الرغم من استراتيجيه القمع غير
المسبوقه وانتاج النظام الايراني
لسلسله من الاجراءات بدء الاعتقالات ثم
الاعدامات ثم همم اختطاف المتظ والمحتاجين
والقاء بهم من فوق اسطح ال- ال- المنازل
والبيوت العاليه مرورا باغتصاب المحتجين
هذا عدا عن
التغيب لعدد كبير من المحتاجين ليس لدى
اهاليهم لغايه هذه اللحظه معلومه
حتى من المتضرر الاكبر اي جناح في داخل
النظام هو المتضرر الاكبر مما يحصل
وهل هناك
جناح همم يسيطر حقيقه همم ويمنع اي تغيير
حدود اي اجراءات على الاقل
سؤال مهم المتضرر الاكبر هو النظام
الايراني المرشد على وجه التحديد
والتيار المتشدد احنا اليوم طاهر بنتحدث
عن وجود تيار ذا لون واحد على الرغم من
التقسيمات يعني الان هنالك ثلاث تقسيمات
اساسيه
للاطياف السياسيه عندنا التيار التيار
الصمود المدعوم من ابراهيم الرئيسي ومن
الحرس الثوري الايراني والذي الان هو
الموجود في اغلبيه كبيره من خلال مجلس
الشورى ومن خلال ايضا مؤسسات الدوله من
الوزراء من المسؤولين هنالك تيار اخر يقود
محمد باقر قلب وهذا التيار ولد من رحمه
التيار المتشدد طبعا هذه لعبه سياسيه طاهر
لمحاوله وبطالب طبعا بالاصلاحات من داخل
النظام الايراني وطرح شعار الامن اولا ثم
الاصلاحات ثانيا لمحاوله اثار الرساله
للشعب الايراني بانه احنا مستعدين لتقديم
التنازلات مستعدين للاصلاح
وهذه الخدعه لم تنطلي ولم تنطلي على
المجتمع الايراني وعلى الشعب الايراني
لانه يوجد تماما هي لعبه سياسيه لتقاس من
الادوار بين هذه الاتجاهات ثم بدا يظهر ما
يسمى بتيار الحجه ايضا المدعوم من الحرس
الثوري الايراني وجود نخب سياسيه وامنيه
هذه تطالب بحل قمع امني وتصعيد هذه
الاجراءات ضد النظام الايراني الجانب
الثاني انه هذه الاحتجاجات طاهر ايضا فوتت
الفرصه على مشتبه حتى يرث والدته لتولي
منصب الارشاد الان احنا بنتحدث عن ثلاث
شخصيات الان ترتبط بالمرشد ميثم ومسعود
ومجتمع همم مجتبه هو الذي يسير ما يسمى
باطناعات رهبري او مخابرات القائد التي
تنظم عمل الاجهزه الامنيه جميع
هذه التظاهرات والتحكم فيها
ظهر على المشهد الان الشعبي الايراني
زياده كراهيه ليس فقط ضد النظام ضد عمليه
التوريث في حال توريث الموضوع الى مجتمعه
لن يمر هذا الامر مرور الكرام ثم الابناء
الثاني من هم الان لديهم ايضا همم وجود من
خلال مؤسسات الدوله عبر ما يسمى بالحرس
الثوري الايراني الذي بدا الان يشدد قبضه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى ايضا النظام الايراني
لم يفلح لغايه هذه اللحظه في تقديم ما
يسمى بالتنازلات صحيح انه جمد او علق ما
يسمى بشرطه الاداب لكن طاهر هنالك كثير من
المؤسسات الامنيه المعنيه بالجانب الامن
الداخلي المعنيه بموضوع الحجاب مثل القوات
التعبئه وايضا القوات التعبئه من النساء
ما يسمى ابن زينبيات وايضا الكوميتيه
وايضا ما يسمى به المخابرات الامن الوقائي
والبحث الجنائي والمشاكل ذلك من اجهزه
امنيه حتى تتفوق على شرطه الاخلاق في هذا
الامر
بيفهم فكره معينه متعلقه بالتيارات في
داخل النظام همم يعني باعتقادك وفقا يعني
لسياسه اذا صح التعبير الخديعه التي تمارس
بشان وجود تيارات مختلفه تنادي
بسيسات اخرى غير سياسه النظام هذا يعني
وفقا لما تفضلت به بانه ليس هناك عمليا
تيارات او اختلافات همم توحي بانه يمكن ان
يحصل همم شرخ في داخل النظام هو نظام اما
يبقى كما هو او يسقط كما هو هل هذا صحيح
يعني ان ان لا زالت يعني علينا يعني ان
نعترف انه اجهزه النظام الايراني لازلت
متماسك على الرغم هذا الظاهر او الاعلاني
لكن فعليا طاهر هنالك اشكاليه حقيقيه في
ما يسمى
بالحرس الثوري الايراني المؤسسات الموازيه
اقصد الحرس الثوري الايراني والجيش
الايراني هنالك اشكاليه حقيقيه خصوصا انه
الحرس الذي يدعم مشتبه الجيش الايراني لا
يدعم وصول المجتمع الى موقع الارشاد يعني
يسمى بتيار روحاني او تيار قريب من التيار
الاصلاح نتيجه للنكيات الموجوده ما بين
المؤسستين خاصه مع وصول ابراهيم رئيسي
اللي اسلم ابراهيم رئيس في نقل قيادات من
الحرس الثوري الايراني لتولي مواقع عديده
في المؤسسه العسكريه الايرانيه بالاضافه
الى ذلك احنا ايضا نتحدث عن وجود خلافات
بين وزاره الاضطراعات وزاره المخابرات
وايضا استخبارات الحرس الثوري الايراني
وهنالك تقاسم للادوار الصحيح لكن هنالك
خلافات شديده بين هذين
المؤسساتين الجانب الثالث ايضا الاجنحه
التي تحاول همم
الاستفاده مما يحدث همم داخل ايران للاساء
الى ابراهيم رئيس يعني هنالك التيار محمد
باقر قريبه هو اول من شانه هجوم على همم
ابراهيم رئيسي وعلى حكومه ابراهيم رئيسي
وصفوها بانها حكومه فاشله لم تحقق اي شيء
هذه ايضا جزء من الخدعه همم ليسار رسائل
الى الداخل والى الخارج ان هنالك تبادل او
همم قبول همم المنافسه السياسيه ضمن تيار
الواحد المشكله انه التيار الاصلي بنخبه
مغير
نتحدث عن امير حسين موسى مهدي الكروبي
محمد خاتمي جزء منهم موجود تحت الاقامه
الجبريه جزء مثل محمد خاتمه ممنوع ان يظهر
على الاعلام او ممنوع التواصل معه حتى لكن
بيعتقد انه الشعب الايراني قد ملا هذا
عمليه تداول تداول السلطه بين التيار
المحافظه والاصلاح لنادي كانس الايراني
يطالب بالموتي
ويطالب بتغيير النظام الايراني ويطالب حتى
بشعارات غير مسبوقه على الرغم من انه يعني
الاحتجاجات اللي صارت في العام 2009 كانت
نتيجه تزوير الانتخابات واصول الرئيس احمد
نجاد على حساب مير حسين الموسوي احتجاجات
اللي صارت في العام 2017 و19 ذات مطالب
اقتصاديه نتيجه رفع الاسعار والتضخم من
انهيار العمله الوطنيه لكن احنا اليوم
نتحدث مش فقط مقتل امين احنا طائر نتحدث
عن ثوره حقيقيه داخل ايران الان بكافه
اطيافه فئات المجتمع الايراني هي ثوره
عابره للقوميات والاقليات في ايران هناك
التضامن غير مسبوق بين الشعوب الفارسيه
وغير الفارسيه
بالاضافه الى ذلك انه همم على الرغم من
انه كما ورد في التقرير قبل قليل لانه
عمليات الاعدام والاستهداف كانت ل- قليلا
بلوشيه او الاقليه العربيه او الشعب
الكردي الا انه هنالك نعم كبير وعارم ما
بين هذه الاقليات وهذا اللي احدث اشكاليه
حقيقيه بالنسبه لانظام اللي كان يلعب
دائما على المذهبيه والطائفيه ووجود ما
يسمى بدوش ماني داخلي العدو الداخلي
المدعوم من القوى الاستقبال العالمي هذه
الخدعه لم تعد تنطري على الشعب الايراني
اللي الان ماشي في مسار هذه الاحتجاجات
ولم يتوقف احنا اليوم نتحدث طاهر على
العمله الوطنيه قبل ما ادخل الاستديو
الدولار وصل
41,500 تومان وهذا رقم فلكي نعم بالنسبه
هذا سوف يكون له انعكاسات خطيره خصوصا مع
ثلاث مؤشرات اساسيه ارتفاع نسبه التضخم ان
هي العمله والنمو الاقتصادي السلبي داخل
ايران ثم انه هنالك قطاعات عديده الان
باتت معطله تماما عن العمل همم نتيجه نقص
الغاز في ايران وبالتالي هذا سوف يرتب مع
دخول همم قطاعات عديده من همم
من العمال من قطاع المترو قيماويات والن
وغير من نادي القطاعات الحيويه والمهمه
على خط هذه التظاهرات سوف يشكل تحدي كبير
بالنسبه لنظام الايراني
دراماتيكيه خطيره خلال الايام القادمه
للدكتور نبيل العتوم رئيس وحده الدراسات
الايرانيه في معهد الشرق الاوسط للاعلام
والدراسات السياسيه من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك
على وجودك معنا الليله يعني نحن مع كل هذه
المعلومات والشروحات همم ورددنا يعني نمدد
الوقت المخصص للشق الداخلي على حساب شق
نووي على ان نناقشه معك في مرات لاحقا ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
اذا تستمر الاحتجاجات في ايران ويستمر
معها قمع النظام للشعب بشتى الوسائل
محاولات حجب الايرانيين عن العالم الخارجي
عبر قطع الانترنت لكن
ادوات رئيس شركه سبيس اكس الون ماسك
المؤثره ماسك
محطه استقبال الارضيه لخدمات الانترنت
المؤمنه عبر شبكه ستار لينك للاقمار
الاصطناعيه تعمل في ايران حاليا تعمل في
داخل ايران الملياردير الامريكي وعد في
سبتمبر باداحه الانترنت عبرته للاقمار
الاصطناعيه في ايران مع فرد سلطات
الايرانيه قيودا متزايده على الوصول
الايرانيين الى الانترنت
قال انه التقط في شوارع ايران حيث توجد
الان حريه اكبر للنساء في اختيار ما اذا
كنا يردن تغطيه شعرهن ام لا وتشهد ايران
منذ السادس عشر من سبتمبر احتجاجات عقب
مقتل الشاب الكرديه الايرانيه محسا انني
بعد ثلاثه ايام من توقيفها من قبل شرطه
الاخلاق لعدم التزامها القواعد الصارمه
لللباس واكدت سلطات مقتله اكثر من 200 شخص
بينما تشير منظمه حقوقيه خارجه ايران الى
مقتل اكثر من 450 من المحتجين على اي قوات
الامن
وقد تم توقيف الالاف على هامش الاحتجاجات
التي تخللها رفع الشعارات مناهضه للسلطات
واعتبر مسؤول جزءا كبيرا منها اعمل شقبا
وفي اوكرانيا حاليا حول 25 الف محطه
استقبال ارضيه في جميع انحاء البلاد
الفارق لا يزال كبيرا بالعدد مع ما ارسل
لايران لكن يبدو ان صوت الايرانيين سيستمر
بالوصول الى العالم لدى ستارلينج حاليا
اكثر من 2000 قمر اصطناعي صغير تدور حول
الارض في مدار منخفض اي على ارتفاع بضع
مئات من الكيلومترات لاتاحه الوصول الى
الانترنت لسكان المناطق الواقعه اسفل لها
لكن كيف تعمل هذه التقنيه
للتمكن من الاتصال بهذه الاقمار
الاصطناعيه يتعين وجوده محطات استقبال
ارضيه توزع كل منها او توزع كل منها
الخدمه للمستخدمين بواسطه اجهزه توجيه
راوتر
الغايه او الهدف ايصال خدمه انترنت رخيصه
وسريعه وايضا ان يقطع الى المسك حصه من
الارباح ارباح قطاع الاتصالات العالميه ما
سيسمح لشركته بربح ما يتراوح بين 30 و 50
مليار دولار سنويا اقمار ماسك صناعيه
لخدمه الانترنت تتميز بان مدارها حول
الارض اقرب من ممثلاتها للدول او الشركات
الاخرى ما سيقلل من انقطاع او تاخر
الانترنت لدى المستقبلين
ايضا سترتبط اقمار ستار لينك مع بعضها
بشعاع ليزر ما سيجعل الناس قادرين على
استخدام الانترنت بشكل مستمر وان تغير
القمر الذي يكون وقتها فوق المنزل لكن
الامر لا يخلو من جوانب سلبيه ايضا
فازدحام المدار بالاقمار الصناعيه قد يزيد
من صعوبه رؤيه الاجسام او الكويكبات التي
قد تصطدم بالارض اضافه بذلك قد تعيق
الاقمار الصناعيه البحث عن كواكب او ثقوب
سوداء جديده ان الامر الاخضر فهو تلبد
مدار الارض بالشغايه في حال ارتطام
الاقمار الصناعيه ببعضها البعض او تصادم
تضايا المتطايره ببعضها
[موسيقى]
طالما ساعه ايران لتمديد نفوذها السياسي
في سوريا لتعلن اليوم اسرائيل عن افشال
مخطط طهران في سوريا رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي اكاد ان السلاح النوويه
الايراني هو اكبر تهديدا محتمل اقليميا
وعالميا
الايراني
لنصب صواريخ في سوريا وانشاء تنظيم اشبه
بحزب الله في الجولان
وتبع هذا المخطط لم يختفي بالكامل ولدينا
المزيد مما يجب فعله في هذا الشهر
[موسيقى]
ستتغير عمليه صنع القرار بالكامل لجميع
اللاعبين في العالم تماما بمجرد ان تمتلك
ايران سلاحا نوويا للاغراض العسكريه لقد
تحسن مستوى استعداد ايران لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي جاهز لاي اوامر ضد نووي ايران
وسيلتزم بالمهام الموكله اليه وقمنا
بالفعل باحباط مخطط ايران لنشر مئات
الصواريخ في سوريا ولدينا المزيد مما
سنفعله
[موسيقى]
والى المزيد من الصور التي تصلنا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه الصوره من
واشنطن لتجمد المياه هناك طبعا ليست
واشنطن وحدها هي التي تشهد هذه الاحوال
الاحوال الطقس البروده الرياح الثلوج
الامطار ولكن العديد من الولايات خاصه في
الشرق وولايات وسط الغرب ورغمى كل ذلك
كانت الارصاد الجويه توقعت ان يتحسن الطقس
في هذه الولايات بعد ايام من البرد القارس
نتيجه العاصفه التي وصفت بعاصفه القرن
والتي اودت بحياه اكثر من 50 شخصا على
الاقل واحدث فوضى كبرى في حركه السفر خلال
عطل اعياد الميلاد راس السنه ونتابع
واياكم هذه الصور اذا التي تريدون من
واشنطن اضافه شكرا
في ولايه نيويورك اضافه الى الصوره الاخرى
من داخل احد مطارات لوس انجلوس اذا من
العديد من المناطق كانت لا تزال تحت تاثير
العاصفه خاصه في بافلو في نيويورك مع
تساقط كثيف همم
للثلوج والعثور على جثث في داخل بعض
السيارات وتحت الثلوج مع تفقد عناصر
الاغاثه المزيد من السيارات بحثا عن ناجين
اذا هذه البحيره هي البحيره المطله على
نصب لينكولن بواسطه
تجمدت مياه هذه البحيره وهذه صور خاصه بها
جره عاصفه
القرن كثر عاده ما يلجاؤنا الى التزلج على
مياه البحيرات
في الغرب عندما تتجمد في فصل الشتاء نتيجه
البروده
القارسا كما يحصل الان اذا في العاصمه
الامريكيه وفي عدد من الولايات الامريكيه
الاخرى اذا كانت الارصاد تحدثت عن تحسن
احوال الطقس في الايام المقبله ولكن ضلت
الدعوات لامكانيه همم او الدعوات للحذر من
السفر الى بعض المناطق هناك بسبب هذه
الاحوال الجويه نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي قبل
ان تابع
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
عدد الوفيات كان ارتفع كما قلنا الى 50
على الاقل طبعا معظم هذه الحالات هي حوادث
الطرق بالمناسبات
اخبار اضافه همم الى تصريحات من المسؤولين
الامريكيين همم مثلا رئيس بلديه بافلو
بايرن براون تحدث همم عن همم امكانيه
ارتفاع او توقع ارتفاع العدد لسوق الحق
وكما قال واا بطبيعه الحال
همم
يعني همم لا احد همم يتمنى ذلك ولكن هذا
ما تقوله الاخبار همم شلل لمده خمسه ايام
خاصه في همم بافلوطي نشاهدها في الجزء
الاوسط من هذه الشاشه امام من شاشتنا
امامكم وكان من المتوقع ان يتساقط المزيد
من الثلوج لهذا اليوم حاكمه ولايه نيويورك
كيف هوشول قالت ان هذه
عاصفه هي اشبه همم او الوضع بعد العاصفه
اشبه بالمنطقه حرب مؤكده انها عاصفه
القرنب كان ركاب وبعد سكان من الفرين من
منازلهم شديده البروده حسروا على الطرق
السريعه مع تعذر التدخل لانقاذهم لان فرق
الطوارئ والانقاذ لم يعد بامكانها طبعا
تحمل همم يعني لم يعد لديها طاقه
استيعابيه همم حزم وهول ما حدث قالت عائله
احدى سكان بافلو انها توفيت في سيارتها
وهي عند تايلور البالغه من العمر اثنتين
و20 سنه فقط بعد ان علقت في طريقها من
المنزل الى العمل اذا همم هذا يعني ابرز
ماي ياتينا من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حتى الان بخصوص عاصفه القرن هذه العواصف
التي ادت الى الغاء نحو 20,000 رحله جويه
في الايام الاخيره بينها نحو اربعه الاف
700 رحله الثلاثاء وفق موقع التتبع
المتخصص فلايت
[موسيقى]
خليجيا شهدت الكويت تساقط البلد في عدد من
المناطق لعلى ابرازها منطقه ميناء الشعيبه
في القصير
وعدد من المحافظات العمانيه ومنها العاصمه
مسقط شهد بطوله امطار متفاوته الغزاره
بدايه من صباح اليوم ما ادى لتعليق
الدراسه في العاصمه تشير توقعات الان الى
استمرار تاثر اجواء السلطنه باخدود جوي
حتى صباح الخميس
[تصفيق]
ومن عمان الى تبوك شمال غرب السعوديه التي
تضرب موعدا سنويا مع الثلوج نشاهد هذه
الصور من تساقط الثلوج على جبال اللوز
[موسيقى]
نعود عليكم
اهلا بكم من جديد توقعات او تنبؤات او
ربما تكون امنيات تلك التي اطلقها الرئيس
السابق ونائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسيه
للعام
23 23
من الناس قديسا وبعد افراد عائله القيصر
وكان منجما يزعم التنبؤ بالمستقبل
التي حملت عناوين عريضه بعيده عن الواقع
باكثر المصطلحات على الاقل التي توقع لها
حربا اهليه تفضي الى انفصال كاليفورنيا
وتكساس
ولليورو الانهيار ولد ولا الاتحاد
الاوروبي التفكك وتحول اسواق المال
العالميه من امريكا واوروبا الى اسيا
توقعات اقرب الى التمنيات ربما
للرئيس الروسي السابق وربما الحالي
على تويتر زياده اسعار النفط الى 150
دولارا للبرميل واسعار الغاز الى خمسه
الاف دولار لكل الف متر مكعب
استيلاء بولندا والمجر على المناطق
الغربيه من اوكرانيا السابقه بحسب وصفه من
اوكرانيا السابقه
ثم انشاء الرايخ الرابع في المانيا
يعقبهم دلاع الحرب بين فرنسا والريخ
الرابع وتقسيم اوروبا
كما لم تسلم ايرلندا الشماليه من تنبؤات
العراف مدفادف التي توقع انفصالها عن
بريطانيا التي ستعود للاتحاد الاوروبي كما
توقع قبل ان ينقسم بدوره
المليار دار الامريكيه ايلون ماسك كان له
نصيبه من توقعات حالف بوتين اذ توقع
انتصار ماسك في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه في بعض الولايات المخصصه
للجمهوريين لكن متى بعد الحرب الاهليه
التي توقعها
ماسك رد سريعا بتهكما واضح ووصف توقعات
الرئيس الروسي السابق بانها سخيفه وقال
مالك تويتر الجديد هذه بالتاكيد اكثر
التنبؤات سخافه سمعتها على الاطلاق والتي
تظهر نقصا نقصا مذهلا في الوعي بتقدم ذكاء
الاصطناعي والطاقه المستدامه
كريستي كريستي
[موسيقى]
سوريا سوريا
كنت
ساكن
في الجامعه الامريكيه اهلا بك معنا دكتور
يعني تصريحات تعيد امريكا واوروبا على
الاقل الى مئات سنين خاصه فترات الحرب
العالميه الاولى والثانيه بالنسبه الى
اوروبا تحديدا هل هذا يقع في اطار الحرب
النفسي الدعائيه
هل يتبع رئيس
بتزيدف هو رجل البوتاغندا في روسيا ولو
تلاحظ ان كل التنبؤات اللي تحدث عنها هي
عن اعداء روسيا متكلمش عن روسيا عن هل
هتنتصر في حرب اوكرانيا قبل لا تنتصر
وضعها مستقبل اقتصادها في 2023 هو بعد
تماما عن هذا الموضوع انما فقط ركز على
اعداء روسيا وشوف مين بيقولوا ايه وهيحصل
لهم ايه وطبعا يعني
الكنبؤات السياسيه موجوده في عبره التاريخ
يعني من اول
المستخدمس لزرقاء اليمامه الى الصحه اللي
بيمسكوا الكريستال بول دي وبيقعدوا يبصوا
فيها وهمم قراءه الكف بس هذا نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي ورئيس السابق وحليف
لبوتن سياسي محمد همم
وهو عارف ان بلد وفي حاله حب فهو طبعا جزء
من حرب النف اللي بيحاول يعملها انه بينشر
هذه الافكار او التمنيات زي ما حضرتك قلت
في البدايه
التنبؤ السياسي ليس سحر انها ما بيعتمدوا
على داتا معلومات وبيانات
تطور تاريخي لما تمسك كل حاجه من اللي
قالها ديت واتحللها علميا هتجد انها فيها
مشاكل ضخمه موضوع الحرب الاهليه الحرب
الاهليه الامريكيه مثلا فقالت 19 كان
الجنوب اقتصاد منفصل تماما يعيش على الريق
الشمال كان صناعي متقدم جدا تكنولوجيا
الان ال- ال- كل الولايات مختلفه تماما
وجود خلافات سياسيه ده لم يؤدي الى حرب
اهليه لان الشعب الامريكي الان بيؤمن به
الديمقراطيه او الانتخابات واحنا شوفنا
حتى لما ابتدى الانفجار ايام سته يناير في
انتخاب بيدن وسقوط ترامب كل اقصى حاجه
حصلت محاولات بعض الفئات انها تهجم على
كونجرس لكن المولات الامريكيه الاخوه لم
تشهد حرب ولا اعلنوا حرب فطبعا الكلام ده
كله من الناحيه العلميه مش حقيقي يعني بس
كده هنشوف احيانا بعض الاحداث التي تذكر
بالتاريخ الامريكي مثل عندما
تستفحل تظاهرات العرقيه مثلا بعد حوادث
معينه بين الشرطه مثلا والتي يقوم بعد
عناصرها بقتل الرجل الاسود عندما يحصل
ايضا حصل عندما رفض ترامب الاعتراف بنتائج
الانتخابات كما حدث في السادس من يناير او
ما يحدث الان في اوكرانيا وكل تابعه ذلك
على اوروبا التي تبدو ايضا من قسمه على
نفسها وقد تقود الى سياسات همم ربما
متهوره او لتحمي نفسها يعني من يدري ما
الذي يمكن ان يحدث في العالم بعد الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه لماذا يجب ان نستبعد
كل ذلك تماما
لا يجب ان نستبعد اي شيء في السياسه لا
يوجد مستحيل او لا يوجد حاجه صعبه لكن
التنبؤات تحدث عنها تنبؤات عايزه وقت طويل
جدا عشان تحدث هذا كلام لكن احنا ما
عندناش هذه المؤشرات اللي بتقول او بتقود
للنتائج اللي هو النهائيه اللي بيتحدث
عنها فاحنا مش شايفين ايوه في مشاكل في
اوروبا مشاكل اقتصاديه لكن هل الوحده
القطيع حطنها لما تكلم ان بريطانيا هترجع
الاتحاد الاوروبي احنا همم بريطانيا لما
عملت البريجزت كان 51% الان الاقتصاد
البريطاني في حاله سيئه جدا هل هم عايزين
يدخلوا ويرجعوا ثاني ده عايز كمان استفتاء
هل في اي مؤشرات الانتخابات البريطانيه
قادمه 2000 24 ويمكن الحزب العمال لو جاء
ما نعرفش هل هو هيبقى مستعد انه يعمل كده
ويعمل استفتاء وندخل ثاني مره ثاني فكل
الحاجه ال- كل التنبؤات اللي تحدث عنها لو
مسكتها هتجد ان فيها مشاكل عديده جدا في
انها تحدث 2023 شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور سعيد
صادق استاذ علم الاجتماع السياسي فالجامعه
الامريكيه تحياتي لك
[موسيقى]
تزايد الحديث في الاونه الاخيره عن السلام
ونهايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا بالطرق
الديبلوماسيه
تفائل العالم وتنفس السعداء لكن مواقف
مشكو وكاف لا تزالوا متباعده رغم الاحاديث
المتكرره عن السلام
التفاؤلؤ الحذر بدده المتحدث باسم الكرام
لندن بالقول ان روسيا لن تجري مفاوضات
بناء على شروط الاخرين ردا على تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيبا بشان عقد قمه
سلام في فبراير من العمل
الصحفيين ان روسيا كانت تنطلق دائما من
شروطها والتفكير سليم ردا على سؤال حول ما
اذا كانت نصف مستعده للتفاوض بشروط اكياف
مناقضا حديث سيد الكرملين قبل ايام عن
استعداد
ان كان يرد تحديدا على تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني الذي اشار الى ان
حكومته تهدف الى عقد قمه السلام بحلول
نهايه فبراير المقبل يفضل ان تكون في
الامم المتحده بحضور الامين العامه تونيغو
تيرش كوسيط المحتمل دي متروك
عندما تدخل الحرب عامها الثاني فكره صيغه
السلام ستكون ذات شقين اولها عدم السماح
لروسيا بالتلاعب بقضيه السلام لانهم
يقولون باستمرار انهم مستعدون للمفاوضات
وهذا غير صحيح لان كل ما يفعلونه في ساحه
المعركه يثبت العكس تماما اما الشوط
الثاني هو محاكمه روسيا عن جرائم الحرب
لكن وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه ذهبت بعيدا
عبر مطالبتها رسميا باستبعد روسيا من
مقعدها الدائم في مجلس الامن الدولي وهو
مطلب لفراس له بالنجاح حاليا مع تمتع
موسكو بحق النقد الفيتو الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ذكرت في بيان ان اوكرانيا تدعو
الدول الاعضاء في الامم المتحده الى حرمان
روسيا الاتحاديه من وضعها كعضو دائم في
مجلس الامن والاستبعادها كليا من الامم
المتحده
دائما في مجلس الامن تناقش اساسا في
الاوساط الدبلوماسيه وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني وبعد ما اوضح ان هذه المساله لم
تطرح بعده في مؤتمرات صحفيه او بيانات
عامه لقاده الدول والحكومات قال انه على
مستوى ادناه يتم طرح السؤال بالفعل حول ما
يجب ان تصبح روسيا حتى لا تشكل تهديدا
للسلام
جانب اخر هام جدا يقع في صلب اي عمليه او
اتفاق سلام متوقع بين موسكو وكياف
التعويضات هل ستدفع روسيا لجارتها الغربيه
فاتوره الحرب وهل يمكن اساسا اجبار موسكو
على الدفع
يجب على روسيا ان تدفع ثمن تحقيق العداله
في نهايه المطاف تلك رؤيه ثابته في كاف
الطريقه او الطرق ربما ليست واضحه حتى
الان لكن الجمعيه العموميه للامم المتحده
اصدرت قرارا غير ملزم في الرابعه عشر من
نوفمبر الماضي ده روسيا الى دفع تعويضات
فعلا
50 دوله في تقديم القرار المتعلق بانشائي
الي دوليا للتعويض عن الاضرار والخسائر
والاصابات فضلا عن سجل لتوفيق الادله
والمطالبات لكنه يبقى غير ملزم ويبقى لي
موسكو وبالتالي هذا يفسر دعوه كوليبالي
بعد روسيا من الامم المتحده ومن مجلس
الامن تحديدا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
قدر رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني في الخامس من
سبتمبر الماضي ان الغزو الروسيه تسبب
باضرار تصل الى
326 مليار دولار فيما وثق باحثون في كليه
كيف الاقتصاد اكثر من 227 مليار دولار من
الاضرار التي لحقت بالعقارات السكنيه وغير
السكنيه بالاضافه الى البنيه التحتيه
الاخرى لكن ذهب بعيدا في تقدير الاضرار اذ
قال في السادس من سبتمبر ان اكثر من
تريليون دولار ستكون مطلوبه لاعاده بناء
اوكرانيا معلنا انها ستكون اكبر مشروع
اقتصادي في اوروبا
ايضا تحديث
الاول حاليا الانضمام
سامي
[موسيقى]
في افغانستان
الداخليه
الافغانيه نذكر بالاخبار العاجله التي
وردت قبل قليل عن مجلس الامن يقول تقييد
عمل النساء يخالف التزامات طالبان تجاه
حقوق الشعب الافغاني ومن عمل للنساء في
المنظمات الحكوميه في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه يحمل تداعيات على عمليات الاغاثه
في افغانستان ويدعو الى مشاركه كامله
وفاعله للنساء والفتيات في افغانستان بعد
ما اعرب عن قلقه الشديد من قرار طالبان
منع الافغانيات من التعليم الجامعي
طيب يا صديقي مذيعه في محطه التيفي واحد
تتحسر على مغادره عدد كبير من زميلاتها
البلد بعد تحولات الاخيره في البلد تقول
ان القيام بالمهام الاعلاميه اصبح صعبا
بالنسبه للمراه الافغانيه
من السيدات وقد قل عددهن بشكل كبير والان
لدينا عدد محدود وقليل جدا منهن شمائله هي
الاخرى من العاملات في محطه التيلفون تعمل
كم مراسله الميدانيه للمحطه تقول انك راسي
زميلاتها شاغره بجنبها وذلك لانهن تركن
العمل وذهبنا خارج البلد
والبعض الاخر استقنا منها الاعلاميه
المجال الاعلامي من المجالات التي لا
تقرها طالب لعمل مراه بينما سيده
الافغانيه تراه مناسبا لعملها وذلك لان
العمل فيه سهل مقارنه بالمجالات الاخرى
يرى العديد من الافغان انه اذا استمر
استبعاد المراه من العمل فانه سيتضرر
ملايين الاسر والاطفال وسيتعين على الشعب
الافغاني التعامل مع ازمه اقتصاديه خطيره
العربيه كابول
فتاه افغانيه تدعى مروى عبرت عن رفضها
قراره طالبا ذلك على طريقتها
بسنواتها 18 تقف مروه على قارعه الطريق في
كابول لكن في قلب الحدث
ترفع فوق راسها لوحه تحدي لقرار طالبان
القاضي باخراج الفتيات من الجامعات
والنساء العاملات من دائره الاقتصاد
وادخالهن دوامه الجهل والبطاله والفقر
بكلمه واحده تواجه ابنه جيل ما بعد طالبان
مقاتل الحركه الذين قفزوا الى السلطه بعد
عقدين من المبيت في الكهوف والجبال اقرا
تريد مروه من قيادات طالبان ان تقرا في
صفحه مستقبل افغانستان لا ماضيها
بالنسبه لها ما هو اهم من المصالحه
الوطنيه التي اخرجت الرئيس الافغاني فار
من البلاد واخضعت مقاتلي وادي بشير
الاسطوري
المصالحه مع المجتمع الافغاني نصفه تحديدا
لا شل هو تعطيله
ان فتاه واحده وقفت ضد طالبان فان ذلك
سيساعدهن على النهوض وهزيمه طالبان
تقف مروه على هذا الطريق وحدها لكن ليست
وحيده
خلفها تيار كبير يرفض مشهد السلاح طالبان
على حقوق المراه
مشهد يؤكد ان المراه والفتاه الافغانيه لا
تقلان فيه شجاعه عن الرجل الافغاني
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 لمتظاهر
فلسطينيه يقف وسط الغاز المسير للدموع
تضامنا مع قضيه الاسرى المحتجزه جثامينهم
ومتحديا للقوات الاسرائيليه خلال احتجاجات
على قرار تل ابيب الاحتفاظ بجثث اسرى
هو في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 سخرا
نجم كره القدم الايراني السابق علي دائما
قيام الامن الايراني باعاده الطائره التي
كانت تقل زوجته وابنته خارج البلاد وقال
اشكر الله ان طائرته ما لم تصب بصواريخ في
اشاره الى اطلاق الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
النار على طائره ركاب اوكرانيه في الثامن
من يناير من 2020 ما ادى الى مقتل 276
راكبا
وفيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من بقاله في
نيويورك التي تغطيها الثلوج العواصف الثلج
الحركه في فتره نهايه الاسبوع هنا في بطل
نرى الحياه
وكانها تجمد تماما
[موسيقى]
ختام العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع فريق اخبار الساعه
كم على محصله اخبار هذا اليوم في جميع
انحاء العالم
ويمثل هذا الفريق صهيب شراير
مساء الخير طاهر انت ممثل وحيد اذا اليوم
لفريق 360 همم طبعا بالاضافه الى العاصفه
انت ختمت طبعا من الاجواء العاصفه في
الولايات المتحده البرد وصلنا هنا اذا في
الخليج العربي انها تمطر في الخارج لعلمك
عندما تغادر الاستوديو الاجواء ماطره ههه
شكرا